[Music]
millions of americans are spending
christmas in need
many suffering from the economic damage
of the pandemic
a texas singer who used to be homeless
is trying to offer cheer
and inspire others to help maria
villarreal shows us how this salvation
army bellringer
is using his voice for good
come and behold
the job is as recognizable as his voice
sammy wade is a bell ringer for the
salvation army's red kettle campaign on
the outskirts of fort worth texas
thing is he doesn't use that famous bell
he sings
across the walmart parking lot for all
to hear
all year has been a time when people
have been in need it was like that all
day
sammy would sing people like wendy lewis
would stop
stare in awe and give merry christmas
beautiful voice i walked out and i heard
this beautiful voice that stopped me
that one voice that one song stopped you
there are people that are hurting and
that are suffering
and the only thing that i can say is
that there is
hope he spent several years homeless the
one constant was his faith and since the
pandemic began
a new church helping him get back on his
feet
sammy has made such an impact on fellow
church members like david bell
that when his car broke down david
volunteered to drive him
i knew that if that job came through
i mean he had a ride that was just never
a question
that's 40 miles from here it's okay
[Music]
working on the red kettle campaign is a
full circle moment for the singer
who struggled after he was released from
prison for a nonviolent offense
three years ago sammy wade used to stay
at the salvation army
maybe social service center and we're
paying him but he's helping us
in return the red kettle campaign gave
sammy a temporary job for the holidays
he's working to get a new car and start
a voice coaching business
but more than anything he wants to help
restore people's faith and remind them
all is not lost i don't feel like crying
anymore
what makes you cry what part of this
i've said so many times
i'm not worthy of all this intention i'm
just someone who
just wants to just be like other people
no matter what
a hopeful soundtrack on a sidewalk in
the age of social distancing
for cbs this morning mireia villarreal
benbrook texas
what a beautiful story well done maria
and a powerful
powerful message there not just his
voice but his story
all of it coming full circle